soulagement dans les départements de
l'ain et de la savoie le gang des
pirates de la route a semble-t-il cesser
de nuire des suspects ont été arrêtés
par la gendarmerie toujours pas
d'amélioration sur le front des
inondations en chine les premiers cas de
choléra se sont déclarés dans ce journal
nous essaierons de comprendre les
raisons de cette catastrophe écologique
la fin des poursuites engagées par les
victimes de l'holocauste et leur
descendance contre les banques suisses
un accord est intervenu les banques
verseront près de 8 milliards de francs
le chanteur nino ferrer est mort il
s'est suicidé dans sa maison du lot on
se souvient du téléphone de mirza du sud
lino ferrer s'était quasiment retiré du
show mise en 75
et puis agde qui accueille le colosse
d'alexandre est reconstituée resterait à
paris
il y sera exposée jusqu'au 30 novembre
madame monsieur bonsoir
ils sévissent est dans les départements
de l'ain et de la savoie depuis le début
de l'été s'en prenant très violemment à
des automobilistes isolé depuis cet
après-midi le gang des pirates de la
route est à priori sous les verrous
après une enquête éclair de la
gendarmerie
benoît gadret et olivier jacquelin les
gendarmes les avaient identifié depuis
plusieurs jours il était placé sous
surveillance étroite
mais pour déclencher l'opération il
manquait lé chef de bande
un homme d'origine marocaine âgé de 23
ans ce matin à 10 heures l'homme a été
repéré après cela six autres individus
ont été arrêtés dont un mineur le plus
âgé ayant 28 ans tous habitent la cité
de rillieux la pape dans la banlieue est
de lyon
c'est ici qu'ils ont été interpellés
passé comme important pour certains
d'entre vous les actes de violence
notamment dans des actes surtout de
délinquance devant lieu je parlerai donc
de vols de voitures de cambriolage puis
quelques-uns de violences également oui
les sept individus interpellés sont donc
soupçonnés d'être les auteurs de huit
agressions particulièrement sauvage la
nuit ou au petit matin ils attaquaient
des automobilistes sur ces petites
routes braquages séquestrations passage
à tabac les victimes étaient dépouillés
de leurs biens
une femme de 60 ans a même été violé en
brûlant ces véhicules volés le commando
espérait faire disparaître toute trace
mais les enquêteurs ont retrouvé des
indices il possède même une empreinte
génétique
quelques appels anonymes ont fait le
reste beaucoup d'éléments à charge à tel
point que dès cet après midi certains
des individus interpellés ont commencé à
reconnaître les faits on leur reproche
des faits de viol en réunion des faits
de séquestration des faits d'enlèvement
des faits de vols avec violences et port
d'armes des faits de vol en bande
organisée a marre mais il encourt pour
ces faits des peines qui vont jusqu'à
trente années de réclusion criminelle
les sept individus seront présentés
vendredi et samedi au juge d'instruction
qui pourraient les mettre en examen
elle est placée sous mandat de dépôt
l'abbé cottard a quitté la maison
d'arrêt de saint brieuc il y était
incarcéré depuis le 25 juillet à la
suite du naufrage qui avait coûté la vie
à quatre ce côté à un plaisancier qui
tentait de leur porter secours
l'abbé cottard était le responsable de
ce camp organisé par des scouts
intégristes jacques devaux et gabriel
camilla c'est en milieu d'après midi que
l'abbé cottard a quitté la maison
d'arrêt de saint brieuc dans la voiture
de son avocat il était incarcéré depuis
le 25 juillet ce matin la chambre
d'accusation de la cour d'appel de
rennes a accepté sa demande de mise en
liberté
laver très fatigué selon son avocat n'a
fait aucune déclaration laissant pas son
défenseur le soin de s'adresser à la
presse et les déchire est cédé 2 de ce
désastre y est déchiré et il ay leila je
pense qu'ils en pleurs cc on ne sonne
peut pas être autrement
cc c'est un homme de coeur c'était un
éducateur un bon éducateur est vraiment
il en est déchiré cette mise en liberté
ne satisfait pas tout le monde à
commencer par l'avocat de madame
cigogneaux la mère du paysan sié qui a
perdu la vie en portant assistance aux
jeunes scouts
pour l'avocat la décote à risque
d'influencer les témoins cottard exerce
sur les familles des victimes et sur les
victimes survivantes car il faut pas
oublier que des victimes survivantes un
des blessés
une telle pression de type sectaire je
dis bien sectaire il sera impossible à
ces gens là de voir la vérité en face
sous même d'accepter que la vérité se
fasse jour libre l'abbé cottard n'en a
pas fini avec la justice
il est poursuivi pour non-assistance à
personne en danger et homicide
involontaire par manquement délibéré aux
règles de sécurité
quatre scouts dont il avait la
responsabilité sont morts après avoir
dérivé 10 heures au large de
perros-guirec
les inondations en chine pour la
première fois le président chinois s'est
rendu dans les régions touchées par la
crue du hantz et on s'attend à un
nouveau pic de cette crue certains
champs prêteuses pétrolifères sont
maintenant menacées par les inondations
et on parle déjà de cas de choléra
jérôme laurent
province du jiangsu à l'est de la chine
ici les crues du fleuve yangtsé ont été
terribles plus d'un million de personnes
se retrouvent sans abri il ya de l'eau
partout
regardez tout est pourri ça pue
les pièces ont pourri et notre enfant
est malade li yang et sa femme vivent
depuis quatre ans sur les rives du
yangtsé dans sa province d'autres
familles ont eu plus de chance
protégée par des digues leurs maisons
n'ont été que partiellement inondées et
les autorités leur ont accordé des
compensations mais pour ceux qui comme
li yang était installé dans les
périphéries des villes dans les
campagnes l'aide a été quasi
inexistantes
personne n'est venu ici cet endroit est
trop éloignée et secours ne vont que
dans les grandes villes
s'il de venir ici il ya juste une petite
route pour l'instant l'urgence ce sont
des médicaments et surtout de l'eau
potable
la saison des pluies n'est pas encore
terminée dans le jiangsu et déjà les
épidémies de choléra et de typhoïde
menace l'eau est empoisonnée est allé
très sale on est obligé de l'utiliser
comme eau potable alors c'est très
dangereux pour notre santé
240 millions de personnes seraient
affectées par ces inondations
ce soir la france a annoncé qu'elle
débloquait une aide d'un demi million
d'un million et demi par don de francs
pour venir au secours de ces populations
en chine un journal officiel a
ouvertement accusé certains cadres
d'être responsable du déboisement
accélérée des régions situées en amont
du fleuve
ce qui aurait joué un rôle dans la
creuse du lion c'est ce fleuve est l'un
des plus grands du monde la chine s'est
enorgueilli de l'avoir domestiquer alors
pour tenter de comprendre les raisons de
ce désastre
les explications de gilles mariné et de
jocelyn la mesure par les dames et
chinoises en retraite il avait préparé
par les soins du gouvernement de nantiat
des pierres de la terre des brouettes
des paniers d'osier la chine de 1945
lutte contre les caprices de ses grands
fleuves avec son arme de toujours les
bras par millions combat millénaire
aujourd'hui encore malgré la
modernisation des défenses et avec leurs
mains que les chinois tente de sauver
les 10 dans le centre du pays
actuellement inondée par le yang tseu
près de 5000 km de barrages dans tout
genre sont censés protéger habitants et
culture autrefois le fleuve s'étendaient
naturellement mais dans cette seule
région 25 millions de personnes occupent
les zones inondables
c'est au cours des siècles et plus
particulièrement au cours des trois
dernières décennies dans ces zones qui
étaient des zones de déversement naturel
des ondes de crues du gave the puisque
toutes les années du coût du paganisme
de la mousson il ya toujours eu et 1998
restera comme une année à la météo
déboussolés on n'avait pas vu cela
depuis 1954
une crue aggravées par la déforestation
en amont du bassin inondées pour dompter
le yang tseu le gouvernement compte sur
le barrage des trois gorges l'emblème
d'une nouvelle chine mais l' ouvrage
colossal qui va créer une retenue de 600
km de long est contesté par les
écologistes et certains spécialistes
occidentaux
il ne pourra pas faire la preuve de son
efficacité avant 2009 date de sa mise en
service
depuis le début de cette crise les
médias officiels chinois ne font que
glorifier l'héroïsme des sauveteurs tant
civils que militaires
pas encore assez d'ailleurs aux yeux des
autorités chinoises qui viennent de
rappeler à l'ordre leurs médias et qui
ont même sanctionner certains cadres du
parti communiste qui n'appliqueraient
pas les ordres venus d'en haut sur cette
propagande autour d'une catastrophe
naturelle
l'analyse de françois corner le
commentaire de la télévision chinoise
sur la bravoure des soldats volant au
secours des victimes est doublé en
anglais avant d'être expédiés par
satellite aux télévisions du monde
entier
pas question pour pékin de prendre le
risque d'une traduction approximative de
ces images de la part des journalistes
étrangers
on apprend ainsi que deux millions de
personnes ont été engagées dans la lutte
dont 700 mille officiers et hommes de
troupe quelques 45 généraux et 2000
officier supérieur dirige les opérations
image dynamique sur le renforcement des
berges du yang ces images émouvantes
parfois sur le sauvetage des riverains
mais rien à la télévision chinoise des
digues qui crac des gens emportés par
les flots déchaînés et rupture
volontaire du fleuve par dynamitage pour
épargner les villes et notamment les
centres industriels la transparence joue
à fond sur les secours mises en oeuvre
par pékin qui aurait déjà renforcé plus
de 2000 kilomètres de rides
en revanche le commentaire est moins
bavard sur l'évolution du bilan qui est
toujours depuis le début selon le
commentaire de 2000 morts rien non plus
sur le nombre réel de personnes
déplacées alors que l'équivalent de près
de la moitié de la superficie de la
france est inondée image rassurante du
premier ministre du 'range' venu sur
place encourager ses troupes
si la nation vous remercie pour vos
sacrifices au service du plus grand
nombre
pas un mot pour les victimes rien sur
l'aide aux déplacés
yang et minent le président chinois y
est allé lui aussi de ses compliments et
de ses encouragements
mais rien non plus sur les conséquences
colossales de cette catastrophe et la
façon dont pékin envisage de gérer la
situation
les journaux de hong kong redevenu
chinoises ne sont pas en reste et font
l'éloge du pouvoir central qui a envoyé
l'armée sur place pour juguler le gang
c'est en angleterre maintenant une bonne
surprise sur le front du chômage
inverse de tous que crédit d'ailleurs
les spécialistes le royaume uni a
enregistré en juillet une forte baisse
du nombre de ses chômeurs ils ne sont
plus que 1 million trois cent trente
cinq mille mais compte tenu des
licenciements massifs non les
entreprises manufacturières on
s'attendait plutôt à des chiffres
inverse à londres valérie fourni du
travail donald macleod n'a pas eu de mal
à en trouver
il s'est même fait prier en négociant
son salaire annuel 30% de plus que son
prédécesseur
les autres varier entre deux cent
quarante mille et trois cent cinquante
mille francs de salaire annuel c'est
vraiment très satisfaisant d'avoir le
choix plutôt qu'un salaire non
négociable s'il a pu négocier c'est que
son secteur est en pleine expansion en
grande bretagne comme les
télécommunications et l'informatique
une extension qui a fait chuter en
juillet le taux de chômage à 87 % un
record depuis 18 ans malgré une crise
profonde dans l'industrie je pense que
nous avons une économie à deux vitesses
avec d'un côté le chômage qui augmente
dans l'industrie surtout au nord et de
l'autre dans le sud du pays
une industrie de services qui voit des
emplois créés mais cela ne durera pas il
y aura beaucoup de chômage dans le futur
l'industrie licencient à tour de bras
il y à un mois rover annoncé 1500
licenciements
hier bien ces grands producteurs de gaz
en données 3800 dont 550 sur le sol
britannique
au total en six mois l'industrie a
supprimé 12 mille emplois le
gouvernement doit changer sa politique
de manière drastique et très vite avant
la fermeture d'autres visent in et la
perte d'autres emplois la livre très
élevé devient aussi un handicap pour
l'économie elle pousse les britanniques
a importé notamment un becquet moins
cher pour leur fameux bois de feu str
hier les éleveurs de porcs manifestaient
leur colère
malgré
vos chiffres de l'emploi demeure ici au
pessimisme
le patronat vient d'annoncer une
récession sérieuse avec la suppression
de cent mille emplois dans les 18
prochains mois et le gouvernement de
tony blair risque bien de traverser à la
rentrée sa première véritable crise
le jeu de yoyo s'est un peu calmée sur
les bourses européennes paris a même
joué à la quasi-stabilité en revanche il
a fallu suspendre les cotations à moscou
pendant 35 minutes la baisse était trop
forte
c'est la deuxième fois en quelques jours
que ce genre d'incident se produit
malgré l'annoncé d'une aide d'urgence
internationale de près de 22 milliards
de dollars
en france la surprise est venue ce matin
d'edf jusqu'à présent grâce à son parc
nucléaire la france exporter son
électricité
mais l'arrêt pour quelques mois de cinq
réacteurs vont la contraindre à se
fournir à l'étranger
en principe la facture pour les
consommateurs ne devraient pas changer
les explications de frédéric retard on
ne peut pas dire qu ici l'ambiance soit
survolté mais il règne une tension
permanente
nous sommes en plein coeur de paris au
centre de contrôle national ddf1 lieu
sous haute surveillance
tous les jours 24 heures sur 24 c'est
techniciens se relaient pour vérifier
que tous les centres de production
fournissent le courant réclamés par les
particuliers et les entreprises
en temps normal avec le nucléaire la
france produit plus qu'elle ne consomme
et moins chers ce qui lui permet de
vendre son courant à l'étranger
nous sommes premier exportateur mondial
seulement voilà le nucléaire a ses
faiblesses
en mai dernier un incident dans les
centrales nouvelle génération de shoes
et civaux met hors service trois
réacteurs
en août un autre problème fait stopper
deux réacteurs à belleville sur loire
ajoutez à cela l'arrêt de la centrale
thermique de gardanne faut faire face
aux besoins et des f a déjà commencé à
importer du courant de toute l'europe à
stocker et même économiser du
combustible nucléaire
une situation que certains syndicats
jugent anormal
l'erreur c'est d'avoir fait pratiquement
une croix sur les moyens de production
classique et un local à nous pour nos
miser essentiellement que sur la
production nucléaire production
nucléaire surexploite elle-même au
maximum la direction ddf n'a pas
souhaité s'exprimer mais elle reconnaît
que cette situation entraînera un manque
à gagner d'un milliard et demi de francs
l'usagé quant à lui n'en subira pas les
conséquences les tarifs de l'électricité
devraient encore baisser
martine aubry l'avait annoncé les
radiologues avait protesté mais le
journal officiel a publié le tarif de
base des actes de radiologie et réduit
temporairement de trait et demi pour
cent ce faisant le gouvernement espère
une économie de 450 millions de francs
pour la sécurité sociale
la victoire au goût amer des victimes de
l'holocauste et de leurs descendants ce
en échange de l'abandon de toute
poursuite pour spoliation les banques
suisses verseront près de 8 milliards de
francs
cet accord met fin aux poursuites
engagées il ya trois ans par des
milliers de victimes dont les avoirs
avaient été confisquées ou en tout cas
jamais restitués par les banques suisses
après la guerre laurent bailly 3 ans de
guerre juridique acharnée et enfin un
dédommagement
les familles des déportés juifs
titulaire d'un compte dans les banques
suisses pendant la guerre ont donc
obtenu 7 milliards de francs 7 milliards
censé racheter aussi lors que les nazis
ont confié à ses banques helvétiques de
leur voler aux familles riches comme aux
millions de pauvres à qui l'on arraché
les dents pour fondre les lingots du
reich pour les survivants de la shoah
pour les descendants des déportés
spoliés par ces banques
ce jour est historique
ça fait longtemps si longtemps qu'on
attendait ça voilà les banques proposées
au départ 180 millions de francs les
victimes réclamaient 20 milliards
plusieurs états américains ont menacé la
suisse de boycott alors les banques ont
fini par céder
elle jure aujourd'hui avoir toujours été
de bonne volonté notre souci premier a
toujours était d'aboutir à un règlement
juste et satisfaisante pour les
survivants de l'holocauste
une brèche sans précédent donc dans la
forteresse bancaire mais les familles
spoliées préviennent pas question d'en
rester là
il y a eu de nombreuses autres banques
et financier criminels qui ont participé
à l'holocauste prochain vers qui nous
allons nous tourner sont les compagnies
d'assurance et après cela les banques
allemandes et encore après les banques
autrichiennes le court promis dans la
sphère des comptes suisses n'est qu'une
étape dans la réparation du préjudice
matériel
le préjudice moral de la shoah lui reste
définitivement irréparable il n'y a pas
de montant qu'il puisse représenter les
cinq des six millions de victimes ça ça
ça n'existe pas ceux qui existent sans
l'existence de comptes numérotés de
dépôt qui ont été faites dans les
banques et qui doivent être restitués en
dehors de ça il n'ya rien à payer
personne n'est habilité aujourd'hui pour
venir réclamer quoi que ce soit au nom
des victimes qui ont disparu
on ne fait pas d'argent sur le choix et
ce soir le premier ministre israélien
ainsi que simon wiesenthal ou serge
classe fel se félicite de cet accord
au kenya les enquêteurs ont annoncé
aujourd'hui qu'ils interrogeaient cinq
personnes à la suite des attentats de
nairobi et de dar es salaam en tanzanie
les attentats qui ont fait plus de 250
morts
l'annoncé a été faite au cours d'une
conférence de presse commune de la
police du kenya et du fbi
quelques minutes seulement après cette
conférence de presse une alerte à la
bombe a obligé à évacuer tout l'immeuble
le fbi a écrit par ailleurs propose
toujours deux millions de dollars pour
toute personne qui fournirait des
informations qui mènerait à une capture
c'est une habitude ou albi à une méthode
qui a déjà fait ses preuves
l'annoncé faite sur internet à coude de
valises pleines de billets jean-marc il
use www heroes point net et sur un site
du département d'état le ministère
américain des affaires étrangères
tout ce que vous devez savoir si vous
possédez des informations sur un acte
terroriste dans le monde
ou si vous êtes un chasseur de primes 4
millions de dollars de récompenses
offertes par le gouvernement américain
dans toutes les langues dont 2 millions
pour les récents attentats en afrique
anonymat garanti charlton heston août
charles bronson les justiciers de
l'écran martèle le même message d
information donnée à temps ont déjà pu
faire échouer des complots terroristes
lesquels motus et bouche cousue voici
tout de même la plus belle prise connu
des services américains ramzi yousef
hommes clés de l'attentât du world trade
center à new york en 93 6 morts et
milliers de blessés
sa faute aux rockets sur des millions de
boîtes d'allumettes serait à l'origine
de son arrestation au pakistan mais
celui là un complices supposés paraît-il
épileptique est toujours recherché ici
le libyen que les américains ron
responsable des 290 morts du vol panam
103 ans 88 4 millions de dollars sur sa
tête deux du gouvernement
deux des compagnies aériennes
depuis 1983 des actes terroristes
internationaux ont fait plus de 800
morts dont une majorité d'américains 5
millions de dollars ont été distribués
officiellement ils ont mené à moins de
dix arrestations environ
c'est peu mais les services spéciaux
n'affiche que rarement leur succès aux
états unis bill clinton en pleurs a
accueilli les corps de dix des douze
victimes américaines
il était accompagné de son épouse hilary
bill clinton qui a commandé un rapport
d'urgence sur la sécurité de toutes les
ambassades américaines à travers le
monde en vue de la renforcer dans la
république du congo la rébellion annonce
qu'elle progresse vers kinshasa il se
serait emparé du barrage d inga au
sud-ouest de la capitale kinshasa qui
est d'ailleurs soir privés d'électricité
pendant ce temps là laurent désiré
kabila et c'est de motiver ses troupes
et annonce qu'il engage des poursuites
judiciaires contre les rebelles du côté
du gouvernement français enfin une
confirmation le ministre délégué à la
coopération fait état de la présence
d'éléments rwandais dans le nord-est du
pays au kosovo maintenant les combats se
poursuivent en attendant une éventuelle
solution diplomatique
le hcr annonce que près de 170 mille
personnes ont déjà dû quitter leur
maison
sans compter les soixante mille réfugiés
les serbes pratiquant ce qu'on appelle
la politique de la terre brûlée
reportage sur place d'eric monnier et de
jean françois renaud la police serbe
multiplie les barrages dans la plaine de
la dre nitza elle en contrôle tous les
grands axes les séparatistes kosovars
ont dû se replier dans la montagne
chievo était une exception
un village où cohabitaient vaille que
vaille serbes et albanais les albanais
ont été chassés 800 serbes sont restés
protégé par quelques dizaines de
policiers
où sont les albanais ou d'ailleurs lui
même ses parkings dernier je sais c'est
qu'on est en sécurité y avait pas eu la
police se serait foutu contre eux ce
qu'ils veulent c'est la grande albanie
ailleurs dans la dream it's a le même
spectacle mais village albanais sont
déserts les maisons détruites
la police serbe mène une politique de
terrebonne pour rencontrer les paysans
albanais il faut quitter la route au
pied de la montagne une école investi
par les déplacés après deux semaines
passées cachés dans la forêt il commence
à peine à oser redescendre mais il faut
bien se ravitailler soigner les malades
vous croyez que vous pouvez rentrer chez
vous non je ne sais pas on a peur
vous voulez vous que j'aille ils ont
brûlé ma maison
les planètes des flics sont installés
dans mon village où aller
en temps normal au nord compte 1500
habitants 6200 déplacés ont envahi ce
village l'un des rares épargnées par la
guerre
rien que chez le vieux mif tard ils sont
85 à avoir trouvé refuge
une ferme transformée en camp de
réfugiés
c'est la guerre selon le haut
commissariat aux réfugiés
ils sont cent soixante sept mille à
avoir fui leurs maisons
les combats continuent et chaque jour
naissent de nouveaux déplacés on se perd
maintenant c'est une série de mesures
qu'on attendait depuis un moment depuis
les réunions de l'union cycliste
internationale à paris à lausanne calais
décidé cette instance supérieure pour
lutter contre le dopage et bien a priori
pas grand chose pour l'essentiel il est
question de limiter le nombre de jours
de course pour les coureurs et pour le
reste et bien essayé de les cogner
simplement de réfléchir avec les
différents laboratoires pour déterminer
le taux de p&o dont un coureur dispose
naturellement dans le sens au delà très
civile bien sûr qu'il serait considéré
comme dopant
météo france avait annoncé des orages
hier soir certains d'entre eux ont été
violents à luz-saint-sauveur dans les
hautes pyrénées la foudre est tombée à
deux reprises sur le même camping
blessantes au deuxième impact trois
personnes
christophe la rocca et benoît d'ordre la
foudre n'a laissé aucune trace sur son
passage hier soir à 19h45 quatre
personnes dînette à cet endroit
cette bâche bleue dressée sur quatre
clics et leur servait d'abri la foudre
s'est abattue dans un bruit
assourdissant
sous les yeux des autres campeurs lui
quelqu'un par terre je pense que c'est
un gosse que tomber une boule qui
faisait 20 cm de diamètre et puis une
flamme un médecin quand le prêt mais
disons c'est quand ta tombe exploser ça
deux personnes parterre de jeunes de
deux saisons à peu près qui étaient
étaient par terre tétanisé quoi et il y
avait une vieille dame qui était keita
couple qui se tenait les oreilles parmi
les trois personnes touchaient une mère
de famille et deux adolescents de 16 ans
l'un d'eux fera un arrêt cardiaque
le propriétaire du camping et départ ce
campeur leur donnera les premiers
secours n'est pas reçue occupé la
première personne qui était là on achète
bouche à bouche il est revenu à lui
rapidement donc on s'est occupé du de
l'eau personnes puis voilà vous avez
fait comme soit la deuxième personne
le deuxième adolescent a été hospitalisé
à lourdes
il faudra attendre 15 jours pour se
prononcer sur son état de santé
aucune réglementation particulière n'est
en vigueur pour prévenir la chute de la
foudre dans les campings les accidents
sont en effet rarissime
contrairement à une vieille croyance les
piquets de tente n'attire pas les
éclairs dans un camping de toute façon
si la foudre tombe c'est surtout à cause
des arbres le pic est normalement et
d'isoler du sol puisque il ya le tapis
de tentes
et puis il ya aussi le capuchon en
plastique au fond au pied du pic est
théoriquement le pick n attire pas la
foudre
il est cependant conseillé de ne pas
camper à proximité d'un sommet et si
l'on se trouve seul sous un orage la
meilleure solution reste de s'allonger
par terre à 100 mètres au moins d'un
arbre ou d'un bâtiment saillants et puis
dans la région de grenoble la pluie est
également à l'origine du déraillement
d'un train qui faisait la liaison gare
de grenoble une coulée de boue s'est
immobilisé sur la voie provoquant ce
déraillement heureusement seuls deux
personnes ont été légèrement blessées le
contrôleur et le conducteur du train et
puis un peu plus haut dans le jura dans
la région de lons le saunier les
pompiers ont dû intervenir à 70 reprises
notamment pour des incendies provoqués
par la foudre
et puis en alsace est un incendie
également qui a provoqué la mort de six
chevaux dans une grange le ciel
décidément fait beaucoup parler de lui
en début de semaine 150 personnes au
moins ont observé un ovni dans la région
de sedan l'objet avait une forme
triangulaire et volait à basse altitude
diego garcia
des images de venir ce n'est pas si
fréquent c'est au beau milieu de la nuit
de lundi à mardi que ce film a été
tourné par deux vidéastes amateurs
d'après le responsable du centre
d'études ovni france il s'agirait bien
d'un objet volant non identifié
on aperçoit quand même de lumière
blanche assez forte avec un point rouge
et le film ne dure qu'une dizaine de
secondes
malheureusement income ils jouent à
cache-cache l'objet jouer à cache cache
il n'a pas pu filmer plus il n'avait pas
le temps de cadres et l'appareil était
déjà parti donc ce centre
150 personnes ont témoigné avoir vu cet
appareil dans la région de ce dont il se
déplaçait lentement avec un bruit sourd
tout à fait inhabituel à la maison donc
il ressemble à un triangle
il ressemble à un triangle où il y
aurait je dis bien il y aurait une
lumière blanche à l'avant de lumière
rouge à l'arrière avec un petit système
de petites lumières au centre avec à
l'arrière
non pas des flammes mais plutôt une
traînée de condensation un petit peu
comme les avions de ligne l'engin aurait
évolué à basse altitude pendant deux
heures avant de disparaître derrière une
colline le centre d'étude des ovnis
écarte l'hypothèse d'un avion furtif
d'un météorite ou d'un hélicoptère
le responsable de ce centre n'exclut
cependant pas la possibilité d'un vol de
prototypes militaire
dernière hypothèse évoquée l'illusion
d'optique un mystère complet
à quelques jours de l'anniversaire de la
mort de la princesse diana les
propriétaires d'un hôtel de saint
germain des prés à paris n'hésite pas à
proposer un circuit très particulier
pour 150 francs tout compris si vous
n'êtes pas client de l'hôtel vous
pourrez refaire le parcours de la
princesse jusqu'au fameux 13e pylônes du
pont de l'alma où elle a trouvé la mort
hervé ghesquière c'est dans cet hôtel
parisien à deux pas de l'odéon qu'a
germé cette drôle d'idée
le directeur de l'établissement veut
commémorer à sa manière le premier
anniversaire de la mort accidentelle de
la princesse de galles puis nous avons
pensé
à l'ariana uniquement 10 connu proche de
son anniversaire et parce que c'est une
très forte demande que nous avons dans
notre clientèle le circuit sera comme
une visite guidée celle des derniers
moments de la vie de lady diana
avec tous les détails du périple fatale
à commencer par l'hôtel ritz
le point de départ est là est sorti par
neuf les cuisines et la mercedes la
tendance est en classe c'est le point de
départ et pour les plus curieux ceux qui
veulent absolument voir et tout savoir
le tunnel de l'alma donc l'accident à
une heure au troisième ligne et vous
avez d'ailleurs un coeur
cette randonnée pour le moins
particulière sera comprise dans le prix
des chambres pour les autres touristes
cela coûtera 150 francs l'heure sur les
lieux à proximité de l'accident
véritable mausolée improvisé à la
mémoire de lady diana
les étrangers en pèlerinage semblent
stupéfaits d'une idée un peu folle c'est
comme un périple à lys lez lens un peu
morbide
si pour faire de l'arrière et je ne
crois pas que ce soit bien vous savez
officiellement l'organisateur du périple
le reverser tous les bénéfices à la
fondation diana un professionnel du
tourisme travaillant pour les bonnes
oeuvres
avouant que ce n'est pas très courant
al'approche de du 15 août et de la fête
traditionnelle des guides de chamonix
les refuges en montagne sont pleins
virginie fichés et thiery simonet sont
allés au dessus de bourg saint maurice
dans un de ces refuges de moyenne
montagne qui accueille est à la fois des
montagnards expérimentés et puis de
simples randonneurs lesueur l'arche vox
éveil georges son gardien enfin une
longue journée premier levé dernier
couché à l'heure où le refuge se
rappelle de sa torpeur lutte prépare
déjà les petits déjeuners des plus
matinaux aujourd'hui ce 6h30 7h ce soap
operas beatles on se lève on se lève pas
très poussé par un refuge de ces deux
heures du matin bientôt à l'odeur du
café emplit les étages lucien theron les
derniers rêves bonjour la se tord à 2000
mètres d'altitude le sommeil émouvoir le
lever le paupières est d'autant plus
difficile mais la montagne n'attend pas
les randonneurs sont motivés moins d'un
quart d'heure plus tard l'aube semble
déjà loin dans la salle commune le goût
des tartines a vaincu les dernières
somnolence en famille ou en son temps
dehors les plus acharnés préparent déjà
leur longue marche les gens traînent
toujours un petit peu mais c'est le
meneur pour monter parce qu'il fait
frère dans les montées donc suffisent à
gré donc ne sont pas assisté au lever du
soleil serait sur les hauteurs on vous
pouvez le voir le mans 5 à 6 heures de
randonnée pour celui ci est une grande
promenade pour cela à cette altitude
on vient aussi vagabonder dans les
alpages en famille
9 heures les derniers promeneurs sont
partis vers les cimes
mais en bas l'effervescence continue
véronique la femme de luxe n'a toujours
pas un moment de répit
si j'avais fini il faut mettre en place
pour le matin tout pour qu'on me dit
mais la salade faire des tartes favé
ghetto pour le soir commencez à préparer
aussi le repas du soir par ce soit il ya
beaucoup de monde
plus d'un millier de randonneurs passent
ici chaque été mais pour ces gardiens
l'arche boc est bien plus qu'une simple
halte se plaindre au monde il ya plein d
il ya plein de gens qui se rend compte
d'ailleurs en refuge se plaindre
romantisme sensibilité se consacrer jans
les gens viennent c'est tout sauf
quelque chose d'un personnel et
véronique éduquer savent de quoi ils
parlent
il ya 14 ans c'est dans un refuge qu'ils
se sont rencontrés au quai du mont-blanc
a connu maintenant sur le départ de la
2e étape de la course en solitaire du
figaro les 45 concurrents okip et
l'irlande sous un ciel typiquement
irlandais d'ailleurs avant de mettre le
cap sur l'île de groix
michel desjoyeaux le vainqueur de la
première étape s'est porté immédiatement
à la poste mais vous le savez rien n'est
joué puisque l'écart entre les six
premiers
mais que de 40 minutes ce qui est très
très peu emballant voile surtout
compliqué encore trois étapes à
parcourir
on a pris tout à l'heure que le chanteur
nino ferrer s'était donné la mort dans
sa maison du lot tout le monde se
souvient de mira du thé les fonds qui
sont et plus tard de cette très belle
chanson le sud du lot ferrer avait 63
ans il avait choisi de se retirer du
showbiz laurent job il y à des hommes
que la terre entière prend pour des
rigolos et qui pourtant voit la vie en
noir
nino ferrer était de ceux là
sa mère est morte en juin dernier il ne
l'a pas supporté
mais ce que tout le monde retiendra de
lui ce sont des chansons légères plein
de second degré j'avais pas vu mirza
c'est par cette question quand 66 nino
ferrer apparaître au public
c'est l'époque des yéyés il faut être
joyeux nino ferrer ancien tube sur tube
mais comme il voit les choses en noir il
introduite au passage un peu de blues
dans la variété française
c'est un colloque de formation on
cultive ce que certains appellent de la
distance inite l égard du vedettariat et
le sobhi saleh que ya ceux qui tissent
entre les bonnes affaires folk et
ramasse plein de pognon
moi c'est le contraire en général quand
je me lance dans une bonne affaire se
termine par une catastrophe financière
et fientes absolument alors ils
s'exilent pour retrouver ses racines
italiennes
ce sont les années 70 ses albums
deviennent concept il aimerait qu'on les
écoute en entier mais le public ne
retient que des tubes à l'italie
les années 80 marqueront pour lui une
ultime rupture avec le système dans le
lot nino ferrer laisse un peu la musique
de côté
il s'adonne à la peinture et se dit sans
illusion cet après midi il s'est donné
la mort deux jours avant son 64e
anniversaire
reçus
hélas
une
et toujours en été
bigot bonsoir vous avez le directeur de
l'iut variétés à france 2 vous avez
beaucoup travaillé avec nino ferrer
c'est curieux parce que quand on écoute
ses chansons à la pression d'un
personnage extraverti drôle et c'était
pas que tout ça mais on a pu sentir même
dans ses propos dans le sujet qu'on
vient de voir que c'était un personnage
hyper sensible et qu'ils étaient
capables à la fois d'une grande
générosité de beaucoup d'humour mais qui
était aussi extrêmement colérique un peu
soupe au lait et puis au sujet à des
sautes d'humeur et à des dépressions
formidable je pense que quand il a voulu
quitter le show biz ou alors qu'il était
au sommet de ses succès et après les
déçus c'est pareil oui voilà au milieu
des années 70 c'est effectivement parce
qu'il était devenu un peu hippie qui il
faisait une musique politique qu'il
souhaitait qu'on écoute et il avait
l'impression que le public ne le suivent
pas forcément et il sait il s'est coupé
assez volontairement du monde pour aller
travailler sa peinture notamment à saint
cyprien dans le sud-ouest de la france
et il en était venu finalement à
détester le showbiz à détester paris et
à ne plus vouloir en fait faire ce qu'il
faut pour faire ce métier
alors il avait fait son come back au
début des années 90 c'est à cette
occasion que j'avais produit deux albums
de nouveautés avec lui et il avait à la
fois beaucoup d'espoir d'être reconnu à
ce qu'il estimait être sa grande valeur
d'artistes et c'est un grand artiste et
il c'était un italien nino ferrer
s'appelait agostino ferrari de son vrai
nom il a eu une grande carrière en
italie en espagne avant même d'arriver
en france et d'être découvert avec ses
ses tubes yéyé rythm'n blues mais il
restait une amertume et en fait il est
reparti de lui même alors là on l'a plus
revu depuis
voilà parce qu'il ne voulait pas jouer
ce jeu qui trouvait totalement factice
du du show business alors france 2 a
décidé de lui rendre hommage ce soir est
donc de rediffuser un taratata qui lui
avait été consacré c'était en 1993 ou
quatre jours à 14 pour nom de ce come
back il avait été invité par nagui pour
une émission spéciale et on pourra donc
le revoir à vers 22h30 ce soir merci
beaucoup et bigot personne n'a oublié
les images du colosse d'alexandrie sorti
de l'eau l'an dernier depuis le colosse
est venu à paris pour se faire soigner
il était en quatre morceaux
et puis le 30 juillet comme tout le
monde il a pris la route du sud
vous pourrez aller l'admirer à halde
jusqu'au 30 novembre benoît thévenet et
stéphane guérison suivi cette migration
estivale qui n'a bien sûr rien à voir
avec celle du géant nous ça on remballe
après quelques semaines passées devant
le petit palais le colosse d'alexandrie
et rhabillé de son ossature métallique
lorsqu'il est arrivé en france tollé
mais était en quatre parties le buste la
tête la couronne et un bras désormais
ils voyagent d'un seul tenant et
fermement attachés et calais
car le principal danger ce sont les
vibrations dans le mouvement de route
des mouvements sur les pièces
tout a été pensé pour les aider
bon là toujours le point d'interrogation
une petite visite de paris by night et
le colosse prend la route au rythme de
50 km/heure le convoi traverse la france
il emprunte les nationale 6 et 7 et
quelques routes départementales une
bonne semaine de voyage avant de
rejoindre agde seule ville avec paris
avoir eu l'autorisation de l'accueillir
un travail de longue haleine nous avons
mis au coin 7 cette manifestation depuis
de plusieurs années j'ai travaillé donc
sur l'idée d'abord de pouvoir réunir
notre musée d'archéologie sous marine
avec les fouilles sous-marines
d'alexandrie à côté du musée les
manoeuvres reprennent le colosse
d'alexandrie pèse 24 tonnes mesure 11
mètres de haut et 3 mètres cinquante de
large pour l'entreprise spécialisée qui
s'occupe de ses déplacements
l'installation à agde est largement plus
compliqué qu'à paris c'est plus
difficile ici parce que le bon le cadre
est différent on a beaucoup moins de
place pour travailler on est c'est plus
joli bien évidemment mais on est mieux
d'hackney des c'est pas facile
plusieurs heures sont nécessaires pour
le remettre debout le socle sur lequel
il repose est réglable par laser afin
d'obtenir une surface parfaitement plane
car un centimètre de décalage à la base
du colosse provoquerait une inclinaison
d'une dizaine de centimètres au sommet
de la statue tollé mais va rester à agde
de trois mois puis le colosse retournera
à alexandrie trois ans après avoir été
sauvés des eaux où il avait sombré
il veillera à nouveau sur la ville comme
il le faisait il ya deux mille trois
cents ans maintenant plus modestes
beaucoup plus modeste que ce colosse
alexandrie ce concours de châteaux de
sable sur une plage de zeebrugge
c'est un must chaque année en belgique
il s'agit de représenter l'un des
monuments les plus importants de bruges
gand anvers bruxelles
on a le choix et si vous passez par là
vous pourrez admirer ces superbes
châteaux de sable la mer ne les aura pas
emporter et puis une substance
mystérieuse a été ajouté aux sables pour
le rendre moins friable donc ces
chefs-d'oeuvre devrait rester en place
quelques jours voire quelques semaines
voilà c'est bientôt la fin de ce journal
je vois appelle les principaux titres
le soulagement dans les départements de
l'ain et de la savoie le gang des
pirates de la route a semble-t-il cesser
de nuire des suspects ont été arrêtés
par la gendarmerie
et puis la fin des poursuites engagées
par les victimes de l'holocauste et leur
descendance contre les banques suisses
un accord est intervenu les banques
verseront près de 8 milliards de fonds
dans un instant vous avez rendez vous
avec patrice drevet fallait avec un
poireau d'abord et ensuite avec patrice
drevet en fait me trompe complètement
s'est passé au vert pour le poireauter
isabelle martinet pour la météo qui nous
annonce une belle journée en perspective
dans l'ensemble quelques nuages dans
l'extrême nord et des orages en montagne
demain à 7h50 dans les 4 vérités
françoise laborde recevra olivier las
vergnas ce qui est président de
l'association française d'astronomie
on parlera bien sûr de la nuit des
étoiles de demain soir sur france 2 qui
aura le plaisir de retrouver de vous
retrouver à 20 heures de marche noire et
je vous souhaite une bonne soirée sur
france 2